große Freude gestern bei einem der
Veranstalter der Demonstration gegen
Rechts in Berlin er nennt es das
Wochenende der Hoffnung und es hat seine
Erwartungen übertroffen ja eine Welle
des Protestes hat dieses Land erfasst
gegen die AFD und gegen Rechtsextreme
Netzwerke so viele Menschen sind auf der
Straße wie dieses Land noch nie gesehen
hat ganz viele Leute das erste Mal es
strömen so viele Menschen herbei dass
die versammlungsfläche schon bald
erweitert werden muss am Ende werden es
über 100.000 sein weil es glaube ich
wichtig ist ein Zeichen zu setzen und
damit wir uns alle bisschen besser
fühlen zu sehen dass wir nicht alleine
sind ich selbst bin ein klassisches
Gastarbeiterkind mit griechischenem
Pass das ist meine Heimat und das ist
mir sehr wichtig heute hier dabei zu
sein ich bin wirklich überrascht worden
durch die Enthüllungen und ja wollen wir
hoffen dass nicht zu spät ist ja von
Rosenheim bis S sind laut dem Bündnis
zusammen gegen Rechts seit Freitag über
anderthalb Millionen Menschen in über
114 Städten auf die Straße gegangen
selbst in Sachsen wo die AFD ihre
Hochburg hat kommen insgesamt über
100000 Menschen zu den Demonstrationen
auch hier befeuern sie die Debatte über
ein Parteiverbot der AFD der CDU
Landeschef und amtierende
Ministerpräsident zeigt sich in der ARD
Sendung Bericht aus Berlin
skeptisch wenn eine Institution eine
Vereinigung eine Partei unsere
freiheitlich demokratische Grundordnung
mit Gewalt abschaffen will und man es
nachweisen kann dann muss man sie
verbieten dann muss man vor das Gericht
ziehen aber viele die das Beobachten
sehen diese Grundvoraussetzung derzeit
nicht gegeben und doch treibt die
Empörung über die AFD auch in München
die Massen auf die Straße mehr als
80.000 kam die Demonstration wurde
abgebrochen wegen Überfüllung
unterdessen haben mehr als anderthalb
Millionen Menschen eine Online Petition
gegen den rechtsextrem Thüringer AFD
Vorsitzenden Björn höcke untersch
er habe sein Grundrecht gewählt zu
werden verwirkt aus moralischen
ethischen rechtlichen Gründen erscheint
mir das sehr plausibel aber wenn wir mir
ehrlich sind wenn sie in der Wahlkabine
stehen und sich schon entschieden haben
die AFD zu wählen dann sehen sie ja
nicht od da steht gar nicht höcke dann
wähle ich jemand anderen also die die
Auswirkung auf das Wahlergebnis der AFD
würde ich für minimal bis gar nicht
einschätzen in Berlin kritisiert
Mitveranstalter Christop BAZ aber auch
die Ampel ihr Versagen trei der AFD wler
zu es sei endlich an der Zeit die
Politik zu
ändern und jetzt ist mir der bayerische
Ministerpräsident aus München
zugeschaltet einen schönen guten Morgen
Markus
Söder guten Morgen grü Gott Herr Söder
sie haben sich ja für das klare Signal
bedankt bei den Demonstrierenden ihr
stellvertretender Ministerpräsident
Hubert eiwanger schriebt dagegen die
Demos gegen Rechts sind vielfach
vielfach von Linksextremisten
unterwandert hat er ein
Wahrnehmungsproblem ich fand es ein sehr
gutes Signal gestern dass so viele
Menschen in Deutschland aufgestanden
sind sich gegen die AFD und ihre Doktrin
wenden das ist ein gutes Signal ich
glaube das sollte mal dieses bürgerliche
Engagement fortsetzen wichtig ist aber
auch dass sich was ändert nicht nur in
der Haltung zur AFD dass es sich
deutlich verbreitert sondern ich glaube
auch die Politik denn die Wahrheit ist
ein Ansatz für AFD Umfragen ist
natürlich viele entus über die
amtierende Politik deswegen wäre glaube
ich wichtig dass diese Demonstrationen
ein Signal der Unterstützung der
bürgerlichen sind gegen die AFD aber
gleichzeitig auch ein wegruf für die
Ampel viele Dinge zu ändern denn wenn
alles teurer und nichts besser wird dann
treibt es der AFD wählertimmenin zuu
aber noch mal die Frage warum wirft der
stellvertretende Ministerpräsident ihres
Landes das Schlaglicht auf vielleicht
ein paar versprengte verpeilte und nicht
auf die große Mehrheit so wie sie es ja
auch getan
haben
ja sie führen jetzt das Interview mit
mir deswegen glaube ich ist das das
entscheidende das zweite ist natürlich
gibt es aber auch gestern in München
beispielwei so dass dann
Vertreter der des Bündnisses die da an
der Spitze standen dann die Ampel
angegriffen haben oder auch zum Teil
sich bei Files V schuture natürlich auch
ganz andere tummeln aber die große
Mehrheit die jetzt dabei war die ganz
große Mehrheit waren bürgerliche waren
Vertreter der normalen Mitte der
Gesellschaft und das ist ein positives
Signal und das muss man jetzt auch
aufgreifen aber wie gesagt es m mü sich
auch Dinge umsetzen und deswegen mein
Appell mein Appell ist zusammenzuhalten
mein Appell ist auch miteinander zu
überlegen und noch einmal dass die Ampel
vielleicht noch mal all das durchdenkt
Olaf Scholz hat ja mal ein
deutschlandpakt angeboten den hat er
dann selbst nicht angenommen man spürt
ja das in der Ampel des intern rumur es
braucht jetzt wirklich einen wegruf auch
für die aktive Politik denn die Straße
ist das eine die eigentliche Politik
muss ja im Parlament passieren und da
ist im Moment viel zu wenig geboten aber
es es nicht ein bisschen schlicht und
ein bisschen einfach jetzt mit dem
Finger nur auf die die Ampel zu zeigen
und zu sagen okay die machen vielleicht
keine gute Politik in der Kommunikation
sind sie auch schlecht das allein kann
ja erstens kein Grund sein in Teilen
eine rechtsextreme Partei zu wählen und
auch die Opposition trägt ja
Verantwortung z.B der Ministerpräsident
aus Nordrhein-Westfalen aber auch der
aus Schleswig heolstein haben beide
gesagt wir sollten uns vielleicht auch
an in eigene Nase fassen wie wir mit
unseren demokratischen ähm ich will gar
nicht sagen Feinden sondern Gegnern
umgehen und ob wir uns da vielleicht in
der tun
und auch im wording also wie man Sachen
formuliert manchmal vergriffen haben
bisschen Selbstkritik vielleicht auch
von
ihnen ich weiß nicht ob das wirklich der
Grund ist wir haben in Bayern auch bei
der Landtagswahl erlebt dass ein großer
Teil der Menschen die AFD gewählt haben
gesagt haben wir wählen die AFD nicht
wegen ihrer Inhalte oder wir spüren auch
dass sie auf dem Weg zu einer
rechtsextremen Partei ist aber uns
verdrie insgesamt die Lage so sehr in
Deutschland dass wir sozusagen als
einzige Möglichkeit einen wegruf zu
senden auch an die amtier NN an an Bund
daran liegt und ich glaube das ist schon
ein Punkt wir haben seit Wochen die
Polarisierung auf den Straßen landwerte
spetiteure Handwerker protestieren
allein wegen den Ungerechtigkeiten die
man ihnen angetein das denken Sie jetzt
an die Landwirtschaft und dieser diese
Stimmung dass alles teurer aber nichts
besser wird dass wir ein Bundeskanzler
haben der scheinbar ausgebrannt wirkt
und überhaupt gar nicht mit der Lage ist
mehr zu kommunizieren das das spüren die
Menschen aber steht denn das Land steht
denn das Land wirklich so schlecht da
wie wie wie es oft beschrieben wird
glauben sie wirklich dass Deutschland so
knapp vor der Wand
steht also ich glaube zumindest dass
Deutschland fast das einzige Land in
Europa ist das im letzten Quartal eine
schrumpfende Wirtschaft hat und ich
glaube fest daran dass es andere Länder
besser machen und dass wir unsere
Chancen die wir haben nicht nutzen wir
nutzen unsere Chancen nicht und die
Ampel selber hat zueinander kein
Vertrauen wenn Sie verschiedene Magazine
vom Wochenende gelesen und dann spüren
Sie auch in der SPD das drüber
nachgedacht wird über Personalwechsel
ähnliches mehr das spüren die Menschen
draußen es wäre meiner nach relativ
leicht mit wenigen aber klaren
Entscheidungen ob in der
Migrationspolitik ob in der Wirtschafts
ob in der Energiepolitik sozusagen das
Schiff wieder auf Kurs zu bringen wenn
das geschieht glaube ich dass auf der
einen Seite die Ampel weniger
Unterstützung bekommt und zum zweiten da
bin ich aber ihrer Meinung wir brauchen
natürlich weiter einen ganz klaren Kurs
gegenüber der AFD diese Partei ist
meiner mein nach verfassungsfeindlich
deswegen muss das jetzt auch gesammelt
und auch eingestuft werden in vielen
Bundesländern ist noch nicht dann mal
die die AFD ein richtig feststehender
Verdachtsfall also wir haben da noch
eine Menge Arbeit bei den Behörden aber
immer stärker immer unverdrossen immer
immer aggressiver tritt die AFD zu Tage
und es muss bekämpft werden also
politisch tut sich ja einiges was haben
sie ja mitbekommen in der
Migrationspolitik gibt es ja jetzt eine
Verschärfung ganz zum Schuss noch sie
haben eine Idee jetzt auch noch mal
erwähnt und zwar die Streichung von
Geldern für die AFD aus den staatlichen
Parteifinanzierung
dazu muss die Verfassungsfeindlichkeit
der gesamten Partei festgestellt werden
das ist ungefähr so langwierig wie ein
Parteiverbot Verfahren helfen solche
Gedanken na ja im Endeffekt überlegen
wir alle auf allen Ebenen was kann man
denn tun ich glaube ein Verbotsverfahren
ist in der Tat extrem schwierig auch
wenn es dem reinem Herzen sicherlich am
leichtesten in sprechen würde ähm wir
stellen dai fest dass es gibt demnächst
dann wohl ein Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgericht da geht's noch
mal die über die NPD und ob unterhalb
der Schwelle eines Verbots Möglichkeiten
gegen solche Parteien sind nach diesem
Urteil wird man etwas klar
ich kann nur sfalls die
verfasschutzbehörden sollen sammel das
was zusammetragen ist wenn ich das noch
kurz erwähnen darf auch bei uns in
Bayern die AFD fordert den Ausschluss
dieses jungen Abgeordneten der mit Sieg
Heil unterschrieben hat und die AFD
Landtagsfraktion verweigert sich bekennt
sich also ganz klar zu der S heilidee so
unsäglich so unerträglich und da braucht
auch eine am Ende rechtliche Reaktion
und das Urteil von dem sie gerade
gesprochen haben wird für Ende Februar
erwartet öder war das der CSU
Ministerpräsident danke für Ihre
Zeit sehr gerne